hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and if you thought that the
previous chapter of black clover was
crazy
this latest installment of the story was
even
crazier not only did we get to see those
two new
overpowered devils in action but we just
got a major dark
triad twist as well we also got a
massive
ancient demon development and osta has
returned
to the forefront of the story as the
clover kingdom itself
is now in direct danger this was
incredible so let's get into it
if you enjoy our black clover videos and
you want us to keep it going
please leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it really does help
and if you're new here or maybe you just
haven't subscribed yet make this the
video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications most of the people who
watch our videos are not subscribed and
then they often come to me and say
man i missed your last video i was not
notified if you want to be notified that
you don't want to miss future videos you
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing
and then hitting that bell and selecting
the option that says all
finally this video will of course
contain black clover
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution
you have been warned the latest chapter
picks up right where the previous
chapter left
off with jack practically nailed to the
wall
and plumande knocked devil trembling as
those two new devils of the highest
order make their presence
felt now noct had expected that these
devils from the top floor of the
cliffhoth would be on par
with the dark triad but he quickly
realizes that they are actually
on a whole other level the names of
these two devils
are lilith and nahama and they appear to
just be playing around with noct and
jack
as they feed on the mana around them by
the way
the names lilith and nahama are likely
another reference to hebrew mysticism
and scripture
just like the sephiroth and cliffhoth
are in some sources
lilith is portrayed as a female demon
from ancient mesopotamian religions
and other sources portray her as the
disobedient
first wife of adam who was eventually
replaced by eve
also in the hebrew bible nahama
is a descendant of kane the man in the
book of genesis who killed his own
brother
abel out of jealousy traditionally both
lilith
and nahama are female nahama was
believed to be a female descendant of
kane however in the black lovers story
lilith appears to be female and the hama
appears to be
male now those dark roots that had
encircled the entire palace in the
previous chapter
appear to be absorbing mana from the
atmosphere and it seems as though this
mana is then being consumed by lilith
and nahama at the same time everyone
outside of the palace is terrified as a
bunch of demonic creatures
storm out and begin causing chaos in the
capital
i'm guessing these are lower level
devils who escaped the underworld
after the cliff off open and we do know
that the devils come
in all sorts of shapes and sizes my
guess
is that these are the low tier npcs of
the underworld
and if that wasn't bad enough it seems
that the ancient demon
inside the spade kingdom capital isn't
done
yet he gets back to his feet while still
actively burning from marijuana's flames
marijuana of course smiles and prepares
to take on the ancient demon yet again
but it looks like the ancient demon
could just be getting
started the chapter then zooms us back
inside the palace
where xenon acknowledges that he
genuinely could not have won against
yuno with only 70 percent of his devil's
power
that in itself is a big deal and it
reveals just how much stronger yuno has
become
in this short period of time and
that's great for yunna and all but there
is no time to celebrate because that is
when another massive twist
occurs now that the first door of the
cliphoth has opened
the barrier that makes the contract
between the dark triad and their devils
incomplete
has been removed and that means that
vanica xenon and dante can
all now use 100 percent of their devil's
power the three siblings transform
into their ultimate forms their 100
devil forms and the clover kingdom mages
know
that they're in trouble serious trouble
the newly powered up and transformed
dark triad members
quickly turned the tables and seized the
momentum in each of their battles
meanwhile knocked is primarily concerned
with the new devils
and morris knocked knows that not taking
out
morris is very dangerous but he can't
get to him
until he gets through those new devils
first
noct realizes that asta's anti-magic
may be the only chance they have to
defeat such overpowered
devils and knocked then seems to suggest
to his devil plumede
that the two of them will have to
sacrifice their lives
right here and now whoa whoa
please don't tell me that noct is about
to be killed off right after being
introduced
we waited for so long to meet the vice
captain of the black bulls
and even though i'm still kinda cheesed
and knocked for telling naked marilona
to put her clothes back
on i have to say that i've gotten to
like knocked as a character
i don't want him to have to sacrifice
himself now after everything
especially since he was the one who made
this entire invasion plan
possible knocked dedicated so much of
his life to this mission
after all the time that he had spent
infiltrating the spade kingdom
but i wouldn't put it past tabata to
kill him off
but i hope that it won't come to that
realistically though
when facing such overpowered devil
villains
it is very possible that some of our
heroes will
end up dying xenon then reveals to yuno
that the spade kingdom capital
is not the only battlefield it turns out
that another ancient demon has been sent
to the clover kingdom
and the people of the clover kingdom are
stunned as a second
gigantic demon approaches them i'm not
sure if this is just
one ancient demon in a single location
potentially the royal capital
or if there are multiple ancient demons
at multiple locations but we'll have to
wait and see either way
this is really bad news for the clover
kingdom and since they weren't expecting
this attack
they are definitely not going to be
prepared i mean how would you even
prepare ahead of time to fight a
gigantic
ancient demon that shouldn't even exist
in the present time
the final panels of this chapter reveal
that the clover kingdom
is now in a critical situation and they
also show
asta and liba during their training
the text asks whether asta will manage
to finish his training in time
and the very last image in the chapter
is that of
asta's face as he breathes heavily after
a tough training session
and so it looks like asta will be
joining the action
sooner than expected since he is still
inside the clover kingdom
he will likely be called upon to test
out his newfound powers
against this ancient demon i have to say
that i wasn't expecting frasta to come
back into the story so
soon but i'm definitely glad i've been
really looking forward to seeing him in
action
now that he has those new powers and now
that he can unite with liba
and it looks like we are about to see
exactly that in the coming chapters
let me know what you guys think were you
expecting the dark triad to reach their
final forms
so soon and what did you think of their
100
transformation personally i think that
all three of their forms
are extremely cool and i'm excited to
find out just how strong these three can
become when they can
access 100 of their devil's power
also what do you guys think about the
new devils and their mana consumption
ability
and is knocked about to sacrifice his
life in order to keep them at bay
finally are you as hyped as i am to see
asta and liba in action definitely share
your thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this black clover video
and you want us to make
more please leave that like it only
takes a second but it really helps a lot
and of course if you like these videos
but you're new to the channel or maybe
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribed
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and
instagram at animeopror a big thank you
to all of our anime uproar patrons who
make videos like this one possible
special thanks to alpha sigma disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all
other clans including in grata the world
acquired respect
pate heffa dr cortman rathee and yx
emperor otaku spidey life canal big
buddhist and tungsten tarcus
finally thank you to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel crews anatoly
kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
font rathune de ora alicia octor bonnie
park sinokami and water
the red-haired raven florian joanne
garcia jack watches anime fat boy games
deadly saint
matthew cruz anthony schreiber hijinks
and mr waffles 247.
if you feel that our videos provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you